hier on a vu les images aussi he et
c'est de plus en plus courant en chile
jacking faux faux livreur faux serrurier
faux voisins toutes les fausses qualités
les faux livreurs notamment qui arrivent
à comme ça faire croire aux gens qu'ils
attendent quelque chose ou qui se
substituent au livreur et d'ailleurs
Coraline vous avez sans doute été repéré
vous par des gens avec une fausse
qualité l'entreprise ngj ouais en fait
une semaine avant j'ai eu des jeunes des
jeunes qui étaient qui sont sont ven
sonner à la porte ah pour me demander si
j'éta intéressé il voulent rentrer à la
maison pour montrer les factures pour
comparer avec leur propres
offrù ils étaient pas sérieux ils
rigolaient il y en a deux qui rigolaient
derrière un qui étaaient un peu plus
sérieux devant mais j'ai voilà j'ai
senti le truc j'ai fermé la porte ouais
repérage ah oui repère non mais c'est du
c'est du repérage ils ont vu que vous
étiez là après sans doute il reste à
côté du domicile pour avoir vos heures
d'entrée et de sortie il repèent sur un
cas d'école il m'ont rappelé le jour
même où la veille ils m'ont dit on est
dans le garage est-ce qu'on peut passer
vous voir vous êtes chez vous j'ai dit
écouté non je suis pas là bien sûr et
pour revenir sur les réseaux sociaux
est-ce que votre montre était visible
sur les réseaux ouais en fait en fait
c'est une montre que j'avais depuis 10
ans donc en fait je la portais et comme
comme je portais je sais pas mes boucles
d'oreilles et puis en fait elle a pris
beaucoup de valeur avec bah ça tout le
lux a pris de la valeur d'un coup ouais
et en fait je je me rendais pas compte
du truc et j'avais une bombe à
retardement autour du poignet je le
savais même pas et Coraline vous avez
été blessé aussi je crois que vous avez
envoyé on a eu des photos de coralina
que vous avez posté d'ailleurs très très
choquant voilà euh non mais c'est c'est
voilà donc c'est mais le problème qu'il
y a c'est que tous les les personnes qui
nous regardent doivent se dire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire donc on nouvre plus à
personne donc c'est ça le truc c'est
quoi aujourd'hui ce que vous faites vous
n'ouvrez plus à personne donc Lucas vous
êtes avec nous merci merci pour votre
invitation alors spécialiste en défense
anticambriolage c'est quoi la méthode
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors déjà
jusqu'à bonjour Merci pour l'invitation
donc déjà déjà avant tout le jaing
concernait avant tout les chefs
d'entreprise alors on vous entend pas
bien est-ce qu'on entend bien monsieur
proto vous m'entendez ah mais
sortez les
deux Saver
s non mais s'il vous plaît est-ce qu'on
entend Lucas s'il vous plaît merci donc
Lucas c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes
spécialiste en défense antiambriolage
dire on Oure plus à personne
malheureusement ces gensl profitent du
fait que on soit très exposé sur les
réseaux sociaux qu'on ne connaît
malheureusement plus nos voisins en fait
par exemple aux États-Unis il font très
souvent des ils font très souvent des
des barbecue entre voisins pourendre à
se connaître pour faire des des
patrouilles et effectivement aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut faire passer pour
votre voisin pu vous ne le saurez pas
quoi donc là on est plutôt sur un cas de
de vol par ruse en fait en réalité avec
usage de violence mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire parce que c'est quoi les
technique parce que aujourd'hui un
voisin on se connait pas tous les
voisins de l'immeuble à un moment il y a
un mec qui vient sur la porte il dit je
suis le voisin même dehors il dit voilà
j'ai besoin de quelque chose donc ça
vient en fait problème qu'il y a
aujourd'hui et et la société c'est ça
qui est grave c'est que maintenant en
fait avant dis il y avait la fête des
voisins il y avait le truc on se disait
c'est un K fa je m'entends bien
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'il faut être
clitré chez soi et ne plus rien faire et
vivre comme comme le fait Coraline parce
que je la comprends tout à fait parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle a été traumatisée
donc c'est c'est n'importe quoi comment
on fait bah en fait si vous voulez on va
devoir retrouver des réflexes qu'on
aurait dans des pays si on était
maintenant expatrié dans un pays comme
l'Afrique du Sud ou par exemple le
Brésil donc des réflexes sont parfois
contraignants dans la vie de tous les
jours c'est quoi les réflexes et ben en
fait tout simplement comme une femme
dans la rue quand elle va éviter de se
faire agresser elle va regarder autour
d'elle va peut-être choisir des tenues
euh peut-être qu'elle n'auraiit pas le
loisir r comp moi je me rappelle à
l'époque à l'époque il y a longtemps mes
parents il disaaiit ch on ira au Brésil
c'est trop dangereux aujourd'hui qui se
passe en France par j'en viiens du
Brésil hein j'étais j'habite j'y habite
d'ailleurs je suis retourné à 3 semaines
parce qu'à la suite des émeutes mon
activité s'est considérablement
développée en France et alors et c'est
c'est pire qu'ici ou pas euh ça dépend
des quartiers sa au polo bien évidemment
vous avez des endroits qui sont
absolument terribles mais globalement ce
genre de phénomène au Brésil n'arrive
pas parce que les gens font beaucoup
plus attention les clôtures sont plus
hautes mais si vousz juste faire
attention monsieur prouto on fait on
fait comment parce que aujourd'hui c'est
quoi la différencere un cambriolage un
homejacking comment on peut se se se se
préserver de ça comprendre l'origine du
phénomène c'est qu'aujourd'hui le trafic
de stupe il est saturé et que les les
caisses des magasins sont vides donc ces
petits malfrain entre guillemets qui
souhaiteraient pouvoir rentrer dans le
domaine du trafic ne peuvent pas
forcément parce qu'ils ont pas forcément
les moyens ni l'espace au niveau
concurrentiel ces gens-là à volé quouz
en vol armé le buraliste du coin manque
de il a plus d'espèce donc qu'est-ce
qu'on reste on va sur Internet on scroll
on regarde une montre une voiture on
regarde le on évalue un petit peu le
rythme de vie de la victime on l'analyse
on la file et puis on attaque et puis
après derrière ben il y a deux écoles
soit ils s'occupent du buain et puis ils
vont flamber ou alors ils vont
réinvestir peut-être dans un trafic plus
illicite mais pour pour nos
téléspectateurs aujourd'hui c'est quoi
aujourd'hui les les les vraiment les
choses à ne pas faire parce qu'on voit
déjà le principe de base cyil c'est de
pas ouvrir à quelqu'un que vous
connaissez pas aux inconnus comme on
dira un enfant ou Siah oui UNP de quand
dans un immeu par exemple tuas tu as les
dératisations tu as le mec qui vient
également pour voir purges d'adiateur en
parlait hier moi je suis désolé quand il
y a une livraison je demande à ce que
les gens livrent en bas au rechaussé je
6e je descends par c'est un principe de
base j'ouvre à personne ça c'est voil
qui RTE le monde que tu qu'on est en
train de un voisin qui est
dangerut chche de l'IDE frppe chez to a
toi qui là les r pas tu regardes dans
l'ouv
pasour les touristes au Brésil par
exemple on leur dit il y a des consignes
qui de ne jamais porter de bag de pas
porter de montrre de pas
porter monsieurout aujourd'hui c'est
c'est quoi Monsieur prouto les trois
choses vraiment à bannir actuementors si
je pis déjà donner un conseil par
rapport tous les gens qui sont les chefs
d'entreprise qui sont ciblés parce
qu'ils sont commerçants parce
travaillent sur les marchés et c'est de
dissocier le siège social de
l'entreprise de leur domicile parce que
ces gens-là vont sur internet sur
socié.com infogreff et cetera même
parfois la CCI vont regarder le domaine
d'activité et puis bien souvent quand on
est entre guillemets un artisan
classique on met son siège social dans
l'entreprise à son domicile même chose
pour les auto-entrepreneurs je l'avais
j'ai déménagé changéême exactement
ensuite pour les personnes âgées qui
sont elles aussi très concerné je dirais
plutôt de mettre on va dire des des de
mettre on va dire des des choses ça peut
êt des jouets pour ENF ça peut être de
laisser entendre qu'en fait ce sont pas
des personnes âgées qui soient isolées
mais peut-être potentiellement qu'il
peut y avoir une famille il peut mettre
par exemple un truc avec Davidson ou
j'en sais rien sur sur le garage mais de
tromper en fait ou chien méchant
exactement chien chien méchant on l'a vu
non mais aujourd'hui c'est quoi parce
que aujourd'hui vous faites des
commandes il y a plein de commandes
delerou Amazon on l'a vu hier c'est
parti de là donc aujourd'hui comment on
fait comme disait Valérie hier en PO
rela hein po relet he ah mais relet
quand vous avez envie de manger à 23h
vous allez all oui oui non oui mais le
camp RER ne sait pas que vous avez
forcément commandé à 18h vousoulez ça va
être livré à 18h30 ils ont ils sont
renseignés mais quand même pas ce c'est
juste pour pas qu'il soit peut-être
parfois repéré aussi mais on fit le
périple normalement du livreur sur sur
la donc on sait exactement où il en est
de la diison et ensuite aller en bas
chercher exactement av une question pour
qui oui pour Monsieur proto allez-y
allez-y quand quand vous disiez petit
malfra je suis désolé mais là quand même
on a l'impression que même il y a des
complicités chez certaines entreprises
dire qu'ils connaissent les horaires
juste avant là on est dans de
l'organisation tout à fait troisème
conseil on pourra en donner 100 des
conseils hein mais c'est des bien faits
effectivement de bien faire une étude de
moralité lorsque les entreprises
recrutent des fois elles sont un petit
peu tentées surtout pendant l'été de
prendre du personnel qui n'est pas
forcément qui ne connaissent pas
forcément j'ai eu plein de cas où ça
souvent des gens qui viennent laver les
piscines voyez qu' vont faire des
travaux de paysagisme et qui donne les
informations j'ai une information de
première main d'un de mes clients qui
est policier on est au stade où les des
des patrons de salle de sport vendent le
listing à des malfras pour savoir qui
est policier pour aller pour aller
chercher chez luicoutez ça c'est
intéressant ça non c'est un policier que
que que j'ai au téléphone pour qui j'ai
équipé de mon mon système de sécurité
mon système de défense et et aussi on
parle aussi des des des des personnes
qui sont devant les restaurants et par
contre on Para Para que parfois aussi il
faut même se méfier des serveurs avec
les histoires de montes aussi qui repère
vousz entendu ça alors alors oui bien
sûr j'entends j'entends effectivement de
tout mais il y a vraiment deux types de
bandit en fait dans le dans le home
jcking vous avez les bandes itinérantes
qui malheureusement viennent souvent de
de de l'Est et qui vont chercher des
marchandises convoité par la violence
pour courtcircuiter le système d'alarme
parce qu'en fait comandoler une maison
aujourd'hui qui est bien protégé sous
alarme ça veut dire que derrière la
police peut être alertée peut être là
rapidement mettre la personne sous
contrainte à plus plus forte raison de
femme c'est plus facile on peut
directement au valeurs mais c'est ça
parce qu'en fait mettre des alarmes tout
ça aujourd'hui c'est plus facile de dire
même quand il y a une maison avec alarm
ça d' aller quand les gens sont là se
dire ben AR cours truc on va les
agresser on vatir plutôt que de mettre
en péril voilà c'est pour ça que
personne n'en parle vous trouverez pas
de grands industriel de la sécurité qui
va mettre l'accent sur le jacking parce
que la vérité ça va n ça va nécessiter
de changer certaines habitudes de vie
que madame va devoir faire
malheureusement à la suite trop tard
mais pour éviter par la suite ou alors
de mettre en place en parallèle des
systèmes de défense qui soit capable de
repousser physiquement le le cambrioleur
mais vous monsieur BR aujourd'hui c'est
c'est c'est quoi aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous avez des exemples de trucs qui se
passent aujourd'hui pour nos
téléspectateurs vraiment de homejcking
comment ça se passe est-ce que vous avez
eu des des des affaires dernièrement euh
voilà ah bah oui quasiment quasiment
j'irai pas j'irai pas tous les jours à
mon niveau mais globalement ça concerne
à la fois les chefs d'entreprise mais de
souvent les chefs d'entreprise ils
savent très bien ils savent très bien
parce que c'est des gens des artisans
qui gagnent de l'argent il y a de la
valeur on on ne se trompe pas le pire
étant j'insiste bien sur ce point si
vous êtes une personne qui est considéré
comme bien gagner sa vie mais que vous
n'avez rien chez vous et que les voleurs
viennent qui pensent que vous avez
quelque chose et que vous n'avez rien là
on va tomber sur le cas qui est arrivé
malheureusement à l'époque à Bernard tap
c'est dire que le drame son drame c'est
qu'il n'avait rien à donner c'est ça ils
veulent faire avouer un truc c'est comme
moi rien j'ai une
playstation vrai j'ai rien mais allez
allez leur expliquer que vous avez rien
vous êtes chef d'entreprise pas ve dire
à vous écoutter que les voleurs
aujourd'hui préfèrent qu'on soit à
domicile plutô j'en suis arrivé à cette
conclusion quelques
Ann à 20h32 préfère que les gens soient
à domicile aujourd'hui plutôt que
système déjà aujourd'hui les
statistiques elles sont très claires
selon l'enquête de vie et sécurité du
gouvernement 31 % des cambrollages sont
tentés en présence des occupants tu bien
de tenter ça veut pas dire que c'est du
homejcking et cetera mais en tout cas
c'est déjà c'est déjà tenté maintenant
bien évidemment pour désactiver un
système d'alarme le mieux c'est de le
faire désactiver de la main même du
propriétaire tout simplement ou il vaut
mieux laisser de tris babioles alors du
coup en évidence il vaut mieux laisser
deux trois babioles en évidence en
fonction de votre en fonction de votre
de votre rythme de vie ça on leur donne
ou rien rien si vous êtes si vous êtes
patron d'une bootte de BTP vous avez 50
salariés qu'ils arrivent chez vous parce
que c'est souvent ça qui sont ciblé hein
outre les personnes âgé qui qui qui vous
dit B non écoutez j'ai pas de liquide
j'ai rien à donner ça va pas faire un
système d'alarme ça coûte extrêmement
cher donc un système d'alarme vous dites
que aujourd'hui il c'est plus c'est
c'est c'est moins bien que que d'Avord
aujourd'hui pour les grands chefs
d'entreprise et cetera est-ce qu'il vaut
mieux pas qu'il prennent une sécurité
même un mec qui a de SCU à domicile 24
24 pour les vous dites les grands chefs
d'entreprise ça c'est mieux qu'une
alarme alors là on parle des gros chefs
d'entreprise qui touche aujourd'hui
c'est petit patron de PME dans les
campagnes en fait he donc que les gros
chefs d'entreprise ils ont une sécurité
24 24 bien sûr eux ils sont même plus
ils sont même moins concerné en fait par
ce par ce domaine sauf cas d'exception
mais après que vous ayez un système
d'alarme qui coûte 500 € ou 3000 € la
police ne viendra pas plus vite bien sûr
ouais c'est ça c'est pareil ah ouais ça
reste des systèmes d'alerte qui
dépendent de l'intervention humaine une
question oui je pose une question non
alors en fait en fait le le truc c'est
que là vous êtes en train de dire qu'il
faut réduire au maximum les interactions
entre les
non justement je dis l'inverse
c'estàdire que malheureusement j'aime
pas dire ça c'est pas un reproche du
tout mais si on connaissait mieux nos
voisins en fait comme ça par exemple
sera pas arrivé voilà c'est ça comme
c'est ce qu'il a dit au début dit aux
États-Unis il font des fêtes ensemble on
va pas connaître les voisins les
livreurs les mecs de
D on va pas faire des soirées toute la
journée on est d'accord
vra quels sont les les outils que vous
pouvez installer à domicile qui peuvent
dissuader non à Monsieur dissuader les
les les personnes qui viennent par que
j'avais j'avais j'avais entendu dire
qu'il y avait des gaz dispersants qui
pouvaient enfin c'est pas j'ai entendu
dire fait un reportage là-dessus sur des
gaz dispersants pour menacer ben non
mais ça ça ça dissuade les personnes qui
viennent là là vous tombez effectivement
dans mon dans dans mon cœur de métier en
réalité hein c'estàd vous avez deux
types de homejcking l'jing on va dire
par ruse très franchement à part mettre
des mesures de prévention c'est
compliqué deéchapper il faut changer
Internet et cetera par contre si
maintenant demain effectivement vous
êtes attaqué à votre domicile ce que je
suggère en fait c'est tout simple c'est
de prendre des gazuses anti-agression
vous connaissez certainement ce sont des
gazuses les fameuses bombes au poivre on
intègre dans un dispositif qu'on peut
activer à l'aide d'un bouton panique
c'està dire que si vous êtes alerté par
votre alarme exemple vous avez une
protection extérieure qui sont rentré
chez vous vous restez dans votre zone de
sécurité vous fermez la porte vous
appuyez sur le bouton ça libère le gaz
le voleur tous pleur ils sont obligés de
sortir et l'avantage c'est que ça passe
mal les portes donc vous vous êtes très
très peu impacté quoi merci en tout cas
merci Monsieur prouto d'avoir été avec
nous et merci merci d'avoir été là
victime d'jcking et on espère que vous
allez pouvoir reprendre une vie normale
très prochainement et merci pour vos
conseils mercici beaucoup on va se
retrouver dans un instant avec on va
parler de Stéphan Plaza puisque il y a
des nouvelles infos voilà je vais vous
dire ce que je pense de ces infos
également dans un instant et puis on va
voir l'histoire du jour elle est
incroyable un chien blesse grièvement un
bébé de 2 mois la maîtresse autorisée à
récupérer l'animal le cri du cœur des
parents du petit garçon cette histoire
on a parlé que de ça aujourd'hui au
bureau c'est une histoire complètement
folle qu'on va vous raconter dans un
instant restez avec nous à tout de
suite